Autism is a disorder where people have problems in three areas.
One is in communication,...
...the second area is in social interaction, how they get along with other people,...
...and the third area is their range of interests.
There are grades of each of these, ranging from mild to severe.
So, for this reason we call it a spectrum.
The latest estimates from the Centers for Disease Control...
...are that one in 88 people are diagnosed with autism spectrum disorder.
The risk is even higher in males,...
...where one in 54 males are getting a diagnosis on the autism spectrum.
We don't know what causes autism right now.
We do know that it has a strong genetic tendency.
There are several genes that have been identified as having an increased risk,...
...but that doesn't begin to explain all the cases of autism that we are seeing nowadays.
But since we don't know what causes autism, we aren't really able to prevent it.